hey what up guys my name is the channel
welcome to episode 66 of game
programming so there are a few changes
going on in the world of game
programming first of all you know as we
move on I've just sort of been thinking
over the last few days the direction of
this series because well when I make
games in my own time I you know I don't
really think about what I need to teach
people so I'm just I've just been
thinking about the best way to do this
stuff and there really is no best way
there is a way it's like there's no best
way because like in order to mater's
game it's based off from the male guard
there are there's a long list of things
we need to do and the order of those
things you know there's no point on
optimize that Auto I'm just going to
teach it in whatever order I feel like
teaching it and I hope you guys are okay
with that but you'll kind of see how
that plays out over the next few weeks
and months probably but we come to a
point we're coming to a point very soon
where you know when I first started this
series at the end of last year I told
you guys that he like basically you guys
would be calling the shelves on this
game and what kind of game is going to
end up being and you guys are kind of
taking create creative and I guess
directorial control of um of this game
ah and by you guys obviously mean you
guys collectively as a group and I just
ask you guys that over the next few
weeks when all this comes into effect
you actually just think kind of
objectively and you know agree with each
other um you know it's going to be the
kind of system I'm probably gonna if I
have time I'll probably make some kind
of app where you guys can convert it for
what you want as well as express your
own personal opinions and everything and
I hope that you guys will be able to
mutually agree on on some concrete
design elements keep in mind that
obviously you know if you really want a
specific you know game design element
implemented that no one else seems to
want ah it's at the end of the world
first of all just think of maybe
another way that it could be merged into
the majority's um aspect of this game so
just think of abstract ways to include
it into the game and then maybe you can
get the support of your peers okay
something like that
I'm just like I just want to tell you
guys that you know over the next few
weeks just try and you know think of it
objectively and you know with a clear
head
because again you guys are going to be
the ones who are going to be guiding
this game into a direction um anyway
enough blabbering today we're going to
talk about the mouse so one thing about
run with the bag got obviously is
whenever you move your mouse and I don't
know if you guys can see my mouth tofu
you can you might want a full screen
from this video basically we move on we
move our mouse somewhere and then we
click and I'll play a shoot in the
direction of wherever our mouse is all
right and we're going to basically start
implementing that today so first off we
need a mouse object right if we go over
here into our game constructor you see
that we've got add killers and this
thing is best for like the pinnacle of
of listeners in in our current set
appear right we're extending canvas so
canvas has a bunch of methods like ad
killers now it's also got ad mouse
listen and focus listeners and
everything so this is like our starting
point right a lot of people and I mean a
lot of people they um they I guess they
just forget about this and so they make
their mouse class or whatever they they
go on they do all of their input stuff
and then it doesn't work and they sit
there and they're like I don't know why
it's not working and nine times out of
ten it's because they just have not
added it into the canvas okay you must
do that so that's why I like starting
with it okay let's add a mouse listener
now we don't actually of a class yet
we've only got a keyboard class here and
we will make a mouse class in a minute
here
we'll just call mouse and we'll also add
a mouse motion listener all right so the
mouse listener as you might imagine
listens for the buttons that we press
and Mouse motion listens for basically
we'll just picks up the location
mouse and all that stuff a mouse okay
and we'll actually create the mouse
object right here so mouse mouse equals
new Mouse we're not going to do it
outside
okay and the reason is all of its
methods are going to be static so
there's no point so let's create the
class and we'll create it now in our
input package which we conveniently
already have okay this way so Mouse the
mouse class implements a bunch of
different things well to the mouse
listener and the mass motion motion
listener all right
and actually think I saw this question
the other day you can implement multiple
interfaces but you cannot extend
multiple classes all right so you can't
you you you in Java you can only extend
one class but you can implement as many
interfaces as you like I don't think
there's actually a limit that might be
but there's not a lot of thing there is
alright so yeah that answers your
question in other programming languages
you can extend multiple classes but you
can't in um in Java which is probably
better that way to be honest okay so we
so here are all of our methods from
these two interfaces right we've got
mouse drag Mouse mail all the stuff
let's just quickly clean this up to make
it look a bit better and then we'll get
on to it
okay there are there are only a handful
here that actually interests us like
Mouse accident Mouse anted we don't need
that stuff oh we might in the future
group I think so so let's make a private
static in cold Mouse X and we'll say
that equal to negative one so it's just
like it's starting value public private
static and mouse y equals negative one
and we'll make one more private static
and mouths B oops equals everyone all
right so why negative 1 instead of 0 for
example because technically like our
mouse could actually be at 0 comma 0 so
in other words if we print out our mouse
coordinate and it says 0 comma 0 we
might be like okay well maybe the mouse
is actually a 0 0 but we know the
negative 1 by negative 1 is not you know
an existing coordinate we can't possibly
put our mouse at negative 1 negative 1
so that way we know it's correct same
with a button okay
so that's the button and these two
variables will basically just store the
location of the mouse on the screen
why shouldn't on the screen on in our
window on our game all right not the
entire screen just again so over here
just under all this stuff actually let's
do it above all this stuff
we'll make a public static int and we'll
call it get X it'll be a method that
returns an integer and all the doors
will just return mail sacks that's it
okay and let's copy and paste that two
more times
oops so get Y and get button and these
will basically just return just make
that be me that Y this lose basically
return these things um and obviously we
have to make the static even though
they're private because um well if we
don't we'll be able to because the
method is static so the con refer to a
dynamic field okay so the way this works
is basically the reason we make all this
soft static first of all because we can
only have one mouse right there is no
way we could have two mouse instances on
the same computer let alone in the same
game so there's that's completely like
there's no does no point making this you
know
have be able to have multiple instances
so you might as well make everything
static that'll make everything with
clean and and technically correct as
well and secondly we need to actually
set all these values to something so in
mousemove right that's that that method
is basically invoked whenever we move
our mouse right and so I guess it's a
good place to probably you know update
our variables so whenever we move the
mouse let's set mouse X equal to II get
X and when we and we'll just same thing
for y right that's pretty much it that's
done we'll talk about dragging
everything later but that's not really
important now so mousepressed right
whenever we press our mouse that's
probably a good time to actually set our
mascot mouse bottom to e dot get button
all right that's all cool but one thing
we have to do with press that we don't
have to do with these two is you know
whenever we press our mouse it's just
going to set that variable equal to the
mouse button that we press but when we
release our mouse it's still going to
remain you know that button obviously
because we're not setting that to
anything else right so when we release
our mouse we want to be able to you know
I guess reset the mouse button so we've
set it to negative one otherwise if we
press our mouse button then release it
the game is going to you know think it's
still press and I'll keep shooting on
for over pretty much so that's one thing
that you need to fix and that is it
right so we'll talk about all that other
stuff later that is actually it okay so
let's go back to our game here let's
save and now everything seems to be
awesome so let's just test this out
scroll down here so those are the three
points I guess when you're adding a
mouse listener right make sure you
actually add them that is step one and
step two may take class that implements
the two interfaces and then just set
variables accordingly okay and here I've
got getter methods to UM to actually
return values okay so let's just take a
look at how this works now in our render
thing let's just over here under our
satphone thing
which we're not actually using so let's
get rid of that am I use it in the
future but you know we probably will use
it in faster future so I'll just leave
it there but G dot fill rectangle at
mouth get X in other words we'll just
we'll just draw a nice little square
wherever our mouse pointer is just to
test out a few mouse pointer works and
we'll just make it like what 32 Suzy 4
by 64 so it's the size of the tile
nothing out tiles are that big
maybe not but yeah so that should work
right so basically she's peeling a
rectangle and the x and y coordinates
are the coordinates of the mouse so
let's just run that and check that out
all right so now our white square is
let's just quickly make this a bit more
aesthetically correct that's right there
just so that it's in the middle looks
nice
okay so now you see that basically our
you know this white square is drawn
wherever our mouse pointer is which is
awesome so that is I guess that's the
beginnings of actually implementing the
mouse now we actually know now we
actually know where our square is I
don't know what I'm talking about now we
actually know where our mouse pointer is
on the screen which is awesome because
then we can calculate which direction to
shoot in okay let's quickly check that
test the button because we haven't done
that and this is why I left the font
thing here so drawstring
button plus a mouse top get button 8080
okay so buttons negative 1 if we press
our left mouse button we get one right
if we press our right mouse button we
get 3 and your mouse button we get to
and it even works for my other mouse
buttons on my razor member Mouse like 5
and 4 but yeah
so there you go we've got all them out
all of our mouse buttons here and
everything works awesomely so yeah
anyway I hope you guys enjoy this video
in fact if Mouse dot get button does not
equal negative 1 and then we could
purchase drawer just so we just saw it
only pops up if we actually press on it
okay sway but yeah hope you guys enjoy
this video if you
please hit the like button and I will
see you guys next time where we'll
probably continue the Mouse stuff lab
guys
you